hélas
je me suis dit que la seule personne qui
pouvait jouer le rôle de cornelius été
une aventure parce qu'il avait à la fois
la force physique en même temps le côté
sympathique et direct chaque il a dans
sa robe ses films et en face de lui j'ai
trouvé que brigitte bardot était fort
bien pour jouer une star du cinéma muet
alors j'ai appris que le couple est
exceptionnel et finalement ça va trop de
cette idée que ces faits le chine
tout devient un gros mot
la pose d'une ampoule la couleur d'une
bouteille ou d'une chemise c'est dément
on demande je demande un truc noir
j'ai répété 25 fois j'ai marqué sa
valise on me l'a portes blanc je crois
que c'est dû au fait aussi des centres
compagne pas au point de vue langue en
fait et qui a un brin de retransmission
et je vraiment je parle de la tour babel
tout à l'heure mais c'est vrai que c'est
ça être impossible de pension et du tour
avec des gens qui parle quatre langues
différentes
de toute façon maintenant aqtim c'est
une entreprise de groupe
je ne pense plus maintenant qu'on aille
voir un acteur spécialement pour cet
acteur est mauvais d'un film aussi mais
avec toute façon des acteurs doivent
être mis en valeur dans un bon film ou
bonne histoire avant metteur en scène
acteur celle où tous s'asseoir avec
parmi d'autres en scène l'histoire de
scénaristes et dialoguistes offert à
tous et bien sûr mais je veux dire que
j'ai besoin de travailler en particulier
des gens avec qui je me sens bien et qui
je communie dans l'histoire du capitaine
tournis qu'est-ce qui vous plaisait
particulièrement parce que c'est un
personnage disponible délice poli pour
tous pour n'importe quoi
décide d'abandonner sa d'un seul coup
parce que décide d'aller voir dans une
île à côté ce qu'il est amoureux de la
mode est donc espèce d'importance mais
la vapeur ils sont là et en attend vous
avez pas envie vous de tout largué deux
partis arrivés